selon certains historiens et politiciens
le moringue réunionnais trouve son
origine au xviiie siècle dans les
grandes exploitations de canne à sucre
le code noir ne permettant pas aux
esclaves de se battre ceux-ci
originaires d'afrique et de madagascar
myrtho point le mort un style de combat
combinant musique notamment les
percussions et techniques martiales afin
de ne point faire naître chez les blancs
la suspicion d'une capacité de révolte
en ne donnant qu'à voir qu'une danse
tribale
mais cette définition est largement
contestée dans les milieux
universitaires réunionnais d'autres
formes de moringue existent notamment à
madagascar
le moringue y est à mayotte le moringue
et billy pratiquants de maurin depuis
près de 30 ans a fait ses propres
recherches
après avoir questionné les anciens de
l'école donc et maladie que c'est un la
paix à terme est néanmoins un petit peu
dans dans le mât lisez et donc madame
redonne à fait pour calmer mon
agressivité donc âprement la jungle un
maïs en train de s'assurer sur la plaza
qu'elle en est après lier mali d'éviter
20 par rapport aux histoires malentendu
côté le site n 46 souvent pas grand
monde sait comment tout ça n avait qu un
personnage l'export dans le moulin g on
en était faux faux faux l'ont fait à la
mas saint paul avec laquelle grand monde
si des dahlias ou capon les alors à
l'usp et faute de cela et à la façon
d'un grand monastère affrontant pour
mater impressionnant parce que
maintenant l'avis commun zone fiat et
épi médias comment es tu te voir que
c'était un moment très important pose en
effet que la demande
une envie qui s'est concrétisée par une
pratique régulière mais aussi par
l'investissement personnel dans une
association
mouren angola mais pourquoi angola et au
brésil en la privant les scarabées bien
d'angola et nous la réunion en
approuvant escales du centre du
mozambique
comme nous l'avons les mélanges les deux
capoeira capoeira angola et maurane
réunionnais et c'est pas ça nous la
donnent le de nous demain nous retrouver
un petit peu le côté africaine n'oublie
pas aussi une racine sur le fond
la pratique locale du moringue ressemble
effectivement à la capoeira brésilienne
les coûts ne sont souvent donné qu'avec
les pieds billy nous explique pourquoi
les esclaves se laver les mains à marc
eder le dos est donc obligé enlève les
chaînes payantes marché donc je ne gagne
pas utiliser braves
j'avais le bras à marie et donc je
suppose à ce que le moringue
ils dansent que righi le combat et faire
cuire tes pieds dans un tp des exercices
sur les navires négriers et danser
danser mais sans utilisent les bras
comme il est souvent dit pour pas que
certains arts et culture ne se perde
il faut les faire évoluer et les adapter
au monde qui les entoure chez les
pratiquants de l'association moore en
angola
pas de cloisonnement la discipline
évolue constamment à nos fans sont là
une morale que de morale que nous fait
c'est un mort un tout-terrain aux médias
qu'elle nous permette confettis liste
canada la nature nous condamne à la paix
at-il à la regarde un haka et brizola
amène les gants sur la transformer et si
cela est montana fait ensemble dal molin
au golan à toute la narine youn et dans
nos oreilles normalement la chinoise
dans à tout pour nous l'importance c'est
pas différent de race mais c'est plus
maître le moigne en l'air ça mais morin
glace a mis ma mauvaise mais va
particulier aux plus longtemps possible
même d avoir un peu plus la relève ici à
la réunion que ya pourtant plus haut
possible
peu importe au final qui pratiquent la
discipline l'important c'est de la
respecte et de la transmettre